yo this show is brought to you by on it
go to onit.com right now
and take a look at that great set of
supplements that'll rock your world
whether it's the protein the chocolate
cacao
protein with 16 grams of scoop or the
alpha brain there's something in there
that you need
go to honor.com right now and press in
church and get 10 percent off number two
one of my favorites mvmt watches over a
million watches sold in over 160
countries and the bottom line is they go
from online to you they cut out the
middleman watches start at 95 all right
go to mvmt right now today and get 15
off with free shipping and free returns
by going to mvmtwatches.com
right now number two
here we go baby
you're sick and tired of sleeping you
don't know your back hurts helix sleep
night after night the same bed
i'm telling you it kills your back go to
helixsleep.com right now
answer some questions and i'll tell you
what i'm going to do if you go to
helixsleep.com joey i'm going to give
you 50 off your order that's
healingsleep.com joey fifty dollars off
your honor do your thing lee let's start
this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] together wash that monkey
it's tuesday morning here we go
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
we ain't [ __ ] around the church or
what's happening now
oh [ __ ]
move your fingers
watch your wallet that pickpockling
people coachella
church of what's happening now coming at
you
april 25th
2017.
oh [ __ ]
here we go
when black people were black people i
just don't know oh [ __ ]
go
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle joey here with my main man of
death
lee syed over there coughing up lungs
and [ __ ] well you give me see you give
me the same wrong heads that you take i
need to take like
i see all these people online taking
bong hits and they go and they take like
a little puff of a cloud and they don't
i need to start doing that those are the
same people who get allergies
they [ __ ] you know they got they put
knee pads on when they ride bicycles
they don't take a chance you gotta take
a chance when you smoke reef for
columbus
i'm taking a chance if you came to the
oxnard shows thank you very much
some of the shows were great
uh
i'm still slipping on stage i'm
stuttering and [ __ ]
but uh it was still a great weekend the
[ __ ] food there levity live
it's the number one [ __ ] kitchen in
comedy right now
really they're really doing a good job
liberty live nyack and oxnard they're
hitting it out of the [ __ ] they even got
to eat something you've never had before
yeah they had me eating kale and [ __ ]
they they tricked me those [ __ ]
i got these steak pies as an appetizer
with like these little onion rings on a
bed of [ __ ] i thought it was spinach
i'm like this spinach is delicious it's
got garlic on it
jesus christ the last night i was there
they told me it was kale i almost died
but what are you gonna do
you gotta take what they're giving you
sometimes that's how my mom used to
trick me i told my mom used to give me
uh
caps uh cow's tongue oh actually it
looked like a steak with potatoes and
that either then she'd go that was cow's
tongue and i'd want to puke to death but
that's i haven't tried lengua i haven't
tried cabezon oh you know you can't know
when you're eating it and then my mom
used to make cab's brains
and you're slicing thin paper thin
you put them in egg batter
with flour and a little [ __ ] italian
breadcrumbs and you're flying fry them
up let me tell you something you squeeze
some lemon on those [ __ ]
you think you're eating a chicken cutlet
after you eat 15 of them they tell you
it's cow's brains you want to shoot
yourself what do brains taste like
delicious when they're fried
delicious i only had them once after my
mom died that's how that's how much i
loved them and a friend of mine said
they made them the same way it was
garbage they were gooey in the inside
i don't like that [ __ ] but anyway no
oxnard was great
i had a great weekend with my family
it's great to have a light schedule guys
like i said when you get older
those airports are [ __ ] tough
every weekend plus i'm lurking in the
middle of the night takes me a few days
to recover thank god i got jiu-jitsu
thank god i move thank god i try to
breathe man i drink water on the flight
i don't drink alcohol you know because
that'll [ __ ] you up
on those flights i'll drink 19 gallons
of water i'll piss every 15 minutes just
on principle
just to keep my legs moving so my ankles
don't swell i'm a chubby dude i stay in
the window seat and i don't move nah
that's why your ankles get all [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] you [ __ ] up your circulation
then the man playing the riding that
plane ain't that [ __ ] good for you so
it's good to take a couple weeks off
i take a plane a few weeks to salt lake
city which is a hop skip and a jump and
then i take a plane to [ __ ] milwaukee
and detroit after that i'm done for like
five weeks man
jesus i'm taking breathers yeah man this
is your longest break i think since
since uh i started with you yeah no but
it won't be a break be honest
you never take a break you make everyone
feel like i i
every time you call it's like i have to
even at night sometimes i'm like he
called after some work i was doing or
something like just you're like you're
always doing something well i break up
the day into eight pieces you know what
i'm saying so you're doing houses you do
an hour and a half here an hour and a
half there and i want to have here an
hour and a half there you go to write
for an hour and a half you're outside in
the sun you come back i go on the
computer i try to [ __ ] around with the
book
i'd sit down later on i sent emails in
the morning i [ __ ] run on twitter and
facebook your day's always organized so
you don't rot to death on that [ __ ]
chat
right now i don't try to do three hour
chunks i don't try to be earnest
hemingway because they'll kill my
[ __ ] back so those days are over with
when i was trying to write this special
those months
i had that back pain it was because i
was sitting
oh really i was sitting in chairs at
denny's i was going to coffee shops i
was going to bars
i was always sitting down writing so i
had to figure something out so now
i just do it in short spurts because it
drives me crazy anyway
i'd rather write a paragraph and get up
and take a walk and sit there for four
hours and burn out like a [ __ ] momo
and then that last paragraph you write
means dick
because you were so [ __ ] your brains
were fried [ __ ] it go give yourself some
air
take a walk smoke a dub
go talk to the cat or something just
break the monotony for a half hour you
deserve it you've been sitting there
yeah it's hard my hardest part is
getting started once i'm working i'm
fine but i think that's why people love
adderall so much and i never tried it
and maybe i should have but like i'll
sit there for eight hours doing like
spinning
pens doing anything but the work i'm
supposed to be doing no sure
what the [ __ ] do you think you're
dealing with
i was like that too for a while and i
needed adderall i just needed to [ __ ]
eat
someone you need to eat
you know it's crazy that i've lived here
for 20 years
and i've seen people
come and go in this town but there's a
certain
and i can't
leave you've been with me five and a
half years now we've been [ __ ] around
yeah have you ever seen me in the five
and a half years go to the celebrity
parties
or want to go to premier league i've
been waiting for my invite i haven't i
haven't got no one cool just don't do
that yeah no
i i could go to parties when i first got
here getting invited to these parties
and i probably went to two of them and i
knew right off the bat i didn't belong
there
like i had just always felt that i
didn't belong don't get me wrong people
spoke to me
and i made people laugh and i mingled
i just always felt like i didn't belong
there because i always felt that the
people that saw me at those things
thought i was there for a reason
so i always tried to
avoid all that type of stuff but aren't
they there for that same reason not
really they're really friends and
they've already made it they're
successful okay you know they deserve to
hang out one another in light of one
another
i've never gotten to that point so
it was just weird that people think
i don't know how to describe this
sometimes that who you hang with or
something
will get you to the next level whether
in film like sometimes i'm watching a
movie
and somebody will say well
the reason why he got there is because
he's such and such as his son
well the reason why he's dead because
he's such and such his nephew or
something like that
and they really don't understand what
people don't understand is that somebody
could walk you to the dance
you still gotta go in there and dance
i think you're mostly right but
especially in that industry in film and
stuff it seems like there's always gonna
be some movie some tv show to hire
people
so i mean is that for like is that i
think in a lot of jobs you're right in
the 20 years i've been here i've been
given maybe three or four roles
that i got a call and they said come on
down and do the work and it was when i
first got here believe it or not like on
pilots for fox or abc
there was a casting director that i
called me twice there was another cast
in the wreck you know so i yes
i can't lie to you but
even if people have you in mind for a
project and this has been the whole time
i've been here i've always had to go
down there and audition
and [ __ ] be prepared
because i always felt that if lisayet
made a call for me
i got to be better than everybody else
when i worked for my in-laws when i got
out of prison
i worked along six [ __ ] guys and i
could look you in the eye
and if i could find any of those guys
today except for mike roebuck we could
call him up right now
they'll tell you that when i worked
i worked
like i didn't talk i didn't share the
chat
i didn't have to rub suntan lotion on
myself and take a break
i [ __ ] got dirty like you know i went
there to work i worked this hard or
harder than anybody else because i was
working for my in-laws
and i never wanted anybody to say i was
a dumb son-in-law
i took a certain pride in that
yeah i mean did you have an experience
with someone who
who like you worked at a place and their
son was an [ __ ] all the time yeah all
the time and you
look at it and go jesus like my friend
venery the guy who owns the premier
impala
when he was a kid he worked
and when i look you in the eye and i
tell you he worked he worked
like when we were 17 his parents would
go to florida for the holidays
and gear would stay home and work in
that funeral parlor
and he knew every aspect of it by the
time he was 18 or 19
he knew how the cleaning would be he
knew the autopsy procedures he knew all
the people he had to deal with to get
death certificates
he knew all that [ __ ] because he did it
from scratch since the time he was
probably 12 or 11. he's probably i mean
not to get you off track but someone
like that he's probably
in the top five percent of all
morticians in the cu he's been doing it
all his life all his life but on the
other hand
you might see a family where they own a
construction
company and
the kid don't do construction but he
drives the best car in town
he has the nicest shoes
so guess what
the guy joins the service
he gets [ __ ] thrown out
he goes to college he never paid
attention in high school so now he has
to turn to the family business
so here's a guy like you
that went in there at 18 and busted his
hump
and now you're 32
and he walks in there and now he's your
boss
this happens across america and across
the world all the [ __ ] time
because the kid goes off he never paid
attention they pampered him as a child
and now he has to actually go work for
the family business and they're not
going to hire him as a [ __ ] goat
because the kids are already mentally
broken
so they're going to give him a cush job
and this guy's going to come in and tell
you what your [ __ ] position he'll
show up at 11 leave it three sure booze
broads a little blow i saw it all the
time
and in a way i wanted to be that
yeah that was the guy i wanted i wanted
to be the kid that your parents gave you
money and you drove the best car in town
and
you did drugs and everybody thought you
were cool that's a great [ __ ] way to
live but good luck
one day that balloon's gonna burst and
you're gonna be left out in the cold
you know i always said that when i was
18 19
beside my thievery i wasn't doing bad
financially working in the city with
numbers i had the drug problem and all
that [ __ ] but beside all that it was a
living and i was good at it and i knew
the ins and out of it
because i did it as a child
were you worried at all i mean i guess
in the grand scheme it's one of the
lesser of your crimes but doing numbers
you were never worried about the general
what's the demeanor in new york city
but misdemeanor's not bad i'm scared of
you i don't even want a misdemeanor no
they disappear after a year
you see a probation officer a few times
you're not gonna get pissed tests
you know those are [ __ ] nothing it's
the ones you get caught
like i got caught for reefer
1980
84 in new york city one of those [ __ ]
years it's 83 it was the year of alvano
and his team won so it had to be 83.
okay
and
i got arrested maybe a month before that
i had to go to court
they gave me like i didn't do deck
like i didn't do dick like probation in
those days was dick
like i went i got arrested there was a
date on the ticket when i had to go to
court i had to go at night eight o'clock
at night
i went down at eight o'clock at night
there was some [ __ ] attorney there he
asked me what my name was
i i told him i shook his hand he goes
all right this is what's going on
the they if you want to take in the
trial they'll take it to trial
but if you want to play bargain there
where they decided on a six-month
deferred sentence
which meant if i didn't get arrested in
six months or in trouble that sentence
would go away
all right that was it i went to court
for basically them to go all right boom
the first sentence
i'm not trying to be an [ __ ] but
you've had you just said you got
arrested a month before that was there
any part of you like [ __ ] i might get
arrested the next six months no no no i
got arrested for that ticket the day
after the super bowl in january like
29th to 30th of that year of 83. okay i
didn't go to court
so the court logged the so backed up
that i didn't go till monday night the
night that they played college
basketball championship so march which
was the last night of march i was on the
street for two months okay and by that
time i had been arrested in new jersey
already that's what i'm saying
possession of stolen tools
possession of [ __ ] uh distribution of
[ __ ] drug no no there was no drugs at
that time
it was all like [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] like
burglaries stolen tools yeah like
burglary tools and [ __ ] like that
so i had already been arrested in jersey
and now i got arrested in new york a
month later but i'm getting out of there
my own reconnaissance
because i told them i've been arrested
in jersey so they already know they know
how to find me you almost have the whole
tri-state area yeah so i almost got the
whole tri-state area so now
i got to go to court in new york city
and i walk in then to do girls boom
deferred sentence
so help me god think all right go see
the court clerk i went to see the court
clerk she gave me like three sheets of
paper
one of them had a number
and he goes call this number between 48
hours a little bit arrest warrant put on
you
and i went home and i [ __ ] called the
guy the next morning why wait the 48
hours i called the next morning
this [ __ ] didn't call me back for 48
hours i called him like four times
left messages called his receptionist
and they said he'll get back to you in
time
he called me up
and he goes what's going on with your
life i told him
he goes was this your first arrest
now i got arrested the month before this
is all done on the phone dawg
i'm in shock i thought i had to hang up
and he was giving me an address to go
report to
he goes this is what i want you to do
what's today's date
i was like i don't [ __ ] know april
3rd or something he goes call me next
month on the
third and i left
that april 25th and i remember calling
him and going listen
i just got to ask you permission or not
i got to go back to court
do you want me to uh
i'm leaving for colorado what do you
want me to do he goes nothing call me
next month and tell me how it is out
there
that's kind of scary and that was it and
we did that
we did that maybe three or four times
and he goes listen your probation's over
yeah don't call no more
are you sure you weren't calling it
sounds like you were calling one of your
buddies
no call him and talk to him i forget
what his [ __ ] name was it was 34
[ __ ] years ago 35 years ago with the
[ __ ] wine it is kind of crazy when
you think of like just if you like going
into a restaurant
and i guess not everyone obviously not
everyone who's on probation is a
terrible person but
you don't know who's in like everywhere
just walking around they just have to
call a probation officer once a month
well now it's completely different okay
now probation's a little bit more
monitored
you know probation is what i call a rope
when i tell you i'm going to give that
person a rope right that's probation
that means that you're going to hang
yourself with it or you're going to pull
yourself in
like seven out of 10 times and they give
you probation not even no no no no no
i'm lying i say six out of 10 times when
you get probation you get arrested but
then [ __ ] let me see if i can google
it yeah it's a tremendous rate it really
is a [ __ ] really weird way
really we weird rate
of what it is a percentage isn't i mean
i mean not
to say that they should be breaking any
laws but is it aren't like the rules
really strict like if
some of them you can't even drink
no no there's different there's
different rules i know when i was under
the influence of all that [ __ ]
there was like if you drank like the
other day i was watching a commercial
they said listerine with no alcohol
right you know why because in the
halfway house people were [ __ ]
failing
left and right some people were lying
they said they were taking listerine
but some people were getting tested on
the way out the door
gee so they were drinking less rain no
they were usually a serene in the
morning you [ __ ] well you don't know
well the only reason i was asked because
i in boston it freaked me out there was
this one homeless dude on the comment
who would drink listerine
all day so i thought i thought that's
what you meant they had to have no list
no alcohol listerine for for the
convicts okay yeah he was drink he drank
a huge rank and if anyone's on uh is in
boston like halfway up tremont street on
one of those benches he's only at least
when i was there he was like he just
lived on that bench and and then you
knew when he was done because the bottle
would turn from uh
green to yellow because he would pee in
the bottle
that's a beautiful story i'm happy you
share that with me
i never knew you were around people like
that people like class like that
it's i surround myself with the best
joey
but
sometimes you hang out with people for
the for the weird reasons
i knew early on when i got here and i
could look you in the face
and tell you honestly
that nobody was gonna do anything for me
but me
do you understand me
and i could give you a thousand examples
and you had friends
i had thousands of friends
who had
huge friends
huge friends
you know i met ahmed
was roommates with vince vaughn
and the other guy
when they wrote swingers
if you watch swingers i met a menace in
the scene or two in the movie oh well i
have to watch it again you understand me
i mean that's that's
everybody gets certain opportunities in
this town it's what you do with that
dance
louis ck
was writing for a show a sketch show he
brought me in i auditioned
louie asked me if i wanted it
but it wasn't like do paperwork i had to
audition
i think i even auditioned for scare
tactics
yes yes i did even though it was given
to me already so like
just so people can understand who aren't
in the like i don't even know i'm
assuming maybe brad pitt doesn't have to
audition no but like level like what
level of people do you think are still
auditioning in movies like or
i'm just not even sure when people go in
when do you think the point is when you
just get called in i think this is how
it is now i think now that
you look at a movie and you attach the
money guy to the movie correct right
yeah
who's gonna draw [ __ ] seats to the
movie unless you want nobody to go to
your [ __ ] movie
all right so you gotta get one of those
people and you gotta pay them [ __ ]
huge
whether it's will smith or tom hanks or
[ __ ] the other guy you gotta pay them
a couple mil 20 mil whatever the [ __ ] it
is
and then you got to make offers out to
supporting actors
kevin bacon
lawrence fishburne so they get offers
they don't even have they don't have to
audition they go to office okay they get
offers and then
if if they read the script and like the
script
and i'm just talking speculation here
they meet with the director
and maybe a producer and they tell them
the vision of what they want from him
and then maybe he'll give his
interpretation
and maybe you'll read
in the room one scene where they want
just not because you didn't get it
and then everybody after that has to
read
i'm sure that there's three or four
people on the set who you just give
roles to because they're friends with
the producer maybe the world is one line
right i had those you know i'm not gonna
lie to you i had those
given to me i told you i bumped into sam
raymond
the guy who put me in spider-man 2 the
director the big time director you
bumped into him recently i went to
listen to me i think
monday
that tuesday
i did the 420 with
doug doug benson and chloe dykstra was
up right and on that show that tuesday
i told the story of how chloe and i met
chloe called into the podcast
in the very beginning of this podcast
i don't remember what i asked her this
is way before we had a live guest
but chloe and i chloe was 14 15 and she
was the little girl on the train with
the glasses up
right yeah so here we are
13 14 [ __ ] years later on the doug
benson show smoking dope
and one of the conversations we had
while we were waiting the tape weren't
you there yeah you were there was about
sam raimi
how cool sam raimi was blah blah blah
blah blah blah
how lucky we were to work with sam raimi
at that time
well here i am two days later
at amazon
and the guy one of the guys
matt
comes over to me that we're pitching
with and he goes hey man i saw y'all
everybody loves doug
um whatever doug getting that with hi
talking about spider-man too he goes i
never knew you were in spider-man 2 and
i'm telling him this story
like that tuesday
like that tuesday afternoon he goes yeah
i watched it for a little while on my
computer at work
he's one of the head writers and stuff
so
or whatever he is a producer or whatever
the [ __ ] he is he's my dog so
the next day we go to pitch
and who the [ __ ]
do you think is sitting in the army
with three other people but sam raymond
oh now i haven't seen sam raymond
in [ __ ] you know 12 13 years since i
was spider-man 2 got shot maybe
summer of 2003
it's [ __ ] 2017. i haven't seen sam
raymond
since we shot the movie and then we had
like a screening
that was the last time he said that's
the last time wow you know
so
here i am in this office i don't say
nothing he didn't recognize you
i didn't want him to
i signed in
and i [ __ ] sat with where i was
sitting which was on the other side of
the room
and i wondered about walking up to him
and shaking his hand and thank him but
no didn't need to
and all of a sudden they called us in
and i'm talking to matt and matt goes
look and as i turn around he's walking
up
and he's walking towards the stairs also
and he's a gentleman so he stops and he
goes like this and listen he looks right
at me
and i go thank you for putting me in
your movie
years ago
and he goes i was looking at you you
look familiar i go yeah i'm the guy in
the train and he was like oh you know i
did the i saw chloe dykstra yesterday
and i told him and he was like wow
that's weird
this is a weird deja vu you know it's
great to see it's great you're still
doing it
you're still pitching you know [ __ ] like
that
that's awesome yeah it was great it was
great just to see him he you know man he
took a chance by putting me in spiderman
too
but that even like that day i didn't
know nobody
i didn't know nobody had an answer i had
an agent those days called nancy apt
all right this [ __ ]
did not [ __ ] around
her office
at that time right
looked like it had been hit by a bomb in
beirut
okay you know when
15 yen from from
97 to
two years ago i didn't really have an
agent people
i had like somebody who was posing as an
agent
but in 98 i signed with a manager
called jeff jeff was a [ __ ] barracuda
jeff did more for me
than anybody in the entertainment
business ever
in a matter of four or five years
but i didn't have the talent
i didn't have the credits i didn't have
my chops yet
i would still go to auditions do a great
read but my hand would be shaking with
the sides
you know i wasn't ready for jeff
but
jeff tried to get me with agents
and the whole time he would always go to
me listen i know you want to sign with
this guy and i know you want to sign
with this guy
but i know this lady at this agency and
i'll go i don't want to sign with that
[ __ ] lady i don't want to be with
that agency
for you to be known you have to be with
a big agency but every agent turned me
down
so i'll never forget a week before
christmas
he talked me into meeting with this
chick
this is
what's the street that turns into the
101
la brea or highland
i think it's highland okay so you're
going up i want you to visualize this
okay you just passed the mall on the
left-hand side you're going to the 101
okay as you're going up
there's a little island
on highland right before you hit that
street where the 7-eleven is and the
[ __ ] subway sandwiches on the corner
that's that's a little island street
as a matter of fact across from there
when i first got here i used to sell
porn on the phone what did i ever tell
you that what the [ __ ] did you what i'm
saying lisa yeah you don't know dick you
you think you're a private investigator
well so this is how bad this
neighborhood was what kind of porn did
you sell on the phone boilers dvds
yeah when i was selling cigars when i
first got here i was selling cigars on
the phone
i would love to hear your porno sales
pitch i was terrible
it was uh
it was maybe 400 a week working
in those days i used to work maybe
10
to 1.
i was pulling down four bills a week
i never even looked at the movies
that's because you read their names like
i never even saw a box i had two options
you could either load the boxes to porno
into the boxes okay or you could call
porno places across the country and sell
them uh porno
i'd rather do that on commission
i would show up at like 9 30. i had war
i used to live on for this is whoa as a
matter of fact
this was way before the cigars
this is when highland
was basically
[ __ ] filthy
like that movie theater was chance
chinese theater what isn't it santa
monica and highland that yum yum donuts
yeah yeah with the transvestite talk
no i don't know if it's santa money i
don't know nothing about santa monica
we're talking about hollywood boulevard
going up to the 101 boulevard highland
that was
in 98 that was a [ __ ] den of death
and in the corn when you went like this
before you folded into the 101
like
30 [ __ ] yards before you hit the
hollywood bowl
right there on that corner they stopped
it was [ __ ] 20 people on the phone
and 20 people stocking boxes and trucks
would be going in and out of there all
day and they either gave you like eight
bucks an hour or you made commission
do you have to have like like i just
imagine you selling gay porn
transvestite i had no idea what i was
selling
there was a sheet of paper and they tell
you what to read on there
yeah hot sex with jim coming on their
ass it's a hot seller and you compare it
to something
i don't remember i don't remember
nothing lately i don't know photography
in this one this is 98 97 i don't know
nothing but anyway to make a long story
short across from there
there was a building that today is
gorgeous but in 98 when i got here and i
was dreaming of this [ __ ] big agency
where they offer you a water [ __ ]
this pla i remember pulling in the uh
into the underground parking and i'm
like oh my god
when we walked up the step there was
little [ __ ] condoms and [ __ ] at least
it had parking i'm like jesus yeah but
no they robbed your car
what good is having parking if you're
gonna rob my [ __ ] car and like we'd
walk up the steps to this elevator
then you pressed it and you went
upstairs
and you the whole building
you know the building we were in
on lancashire right that's what it was
but that's my agency
people [ __ ] taking naked pictures in
there
they had private investigators in there
you know it was just a [ __ ] greasy
building and here's this [ __ ] agency
and i open up the door with my [ __ ]
manager at the time he goes listen to me
it's not the agency it's the agent
he goes excuse me excuse me he goes
this lady
he goes i've been here and i've been
there and i got my own management
company
and this lady is a [ __ ] pimple
jesus
and uh
yeah i guess it really doesn't matter
which lady but it's scary it didn't
matter like she got she called in she
had been in a big agency for like 10
years she knew everybody in town
and one day she got sick and tired of
wearing a dress
she wanted to wear [ __ ] sweatpants
not do her hair and bring her dog to
work
so she went to work at this place and
she took a [ __ ] huge clientele but
this lady never stopped when i tell you
lee
she was on my phone every [ __ ] day
pushing me and she specialized
in comedy car
comedy character actors
so her and i clicked right off the bat
we must have booked
15 things together that's how good and
precise she was i'm surprised she's not
still one of your agents she disa she
abandoned ship
she went back home for a while
and then she came back
and she thought about it
she thought about joining going to aqua
agency
which if she would have gone to aqua
agency with the knowledge she had today
she would have killed it because aqua is
one of those small agencies
that if you sign with them you're gonna
audition
like if you sign with awkward talent
like i was with them in the commercial
department
there wasn't one week
for three years that i didn't go out and
audition
either they got you something that you
were right for or you went in for a
[ __ ] asian
they didn't give a [ __ ] they got you out
they kept you sharp they were very smart
they kept you sharp sometimes they'd
send you out for those [ __ ] demos
where you got 300 hours for the day and
you didn't get residuals but they kept
you sharp
and i was very impressed with that
the whole point is to keep you working
the whole point was when i left them i
didn't leave them because i wasn't happy
with them i left them because i was
trying to get into voiceovers
so every eight people think that you
come out here just like me
that you come out here and you have to
lock in with a big agency
and that's [ __ ]
even when i first came out here i signed
with an agency called the coloring book
did i ever tell you that yeah that's the
the two black ladies the two black
chicks and the agency was like a kid's
agency
okay you know how embarrassing that was
like everybody else's paper like in
those days you had to put your resume
behind your headshot and staple it
okay so it would have to be perfect
eight by ten
so i would go to [ __ ] by the way it's
closed whatever harry wong [ __ ]
printing and
on sunset boulevard went under right
next to compadre
that's [ __ ] that's a heartbreak that
place had been there since jesus was
chicago dog
but anyway you have to have it most
people wanted that paper work white
but in a good way
she made you put a pink
yeah well yeah
it stands out so she was very smart in
that department you just didn't like
having paint paper
she [ __ ] closed my deal
with the bronx
county that time
and she did something else she got me a
couple things that i sat there and went
wow how did you get me into this
like she was that good too
she just disappeared one day also
it's crazy the percentages of small
agencies out they make a run for it and
then they crumble something happens
and everybody runs
at that time i was at with three agents
at one time
like i was working three agents at one
time is that allowed no
there was no computer that the computer
hadn't been involved in okay computer
really didn't get involved electronic
submissions
didn't really start till maybe like 2004
so till 2004 i had a rain here like six
years
that i had three different agents
sending me out for three different
and they were truly like i told you it's
really weird what i learned but back to
the situation at hand [ __ ]
before you throw me off again i'm sorry
adam sandler's nephew great kid i forget
what his name is
great kid just a [ __ ] him and his
sister agree i met him when he was
really young
when i did the longest yard he called me
in years later to do one of his short
films
i had a great time i got invited to the
premiere and stuff like that
you know you think somebody like that
by now would be a huge
director in this town no
he's still out there fighting for his
[ __ ] life
adam could make a call
adam could make a call but guess what
i don't think adam would want to make a
call and i don't think his nephew would
want him to make that call
do you know what i'm saying
uh yeah yeah i uh the the only reason i
got my first job in la was because i
went to emerson so that was one and then
b my dad knew the host of the show so he
called and i got the internship
so
it's uh
when i when i left that first job it was
i i really
uh made a point to try to get it like i
i
and it hurts me too but i always try to
do it without other people's help
i feel like at a certain point i should
you should ask for help
but yeah it does bring a certain amount
of pride to just do it
just apply it or just do anything just
from start to finish on your own
like uh
i was struggling wrong as a distortion
was telling me he listened to a podcast
or whatever his name is
and he was saying that
joe had done this and this and this for
me it's so weird
i sat down you know what joe took me on
the road
but when nobody knows in the beginning
when i first met joe
he used to take chris mcguire on the
road
all right it was when i first met joe
joe was just starting to go on the road
i was going on the road on my own as a
feature act
i really didn't have anybody taking me
on the road
i remember i would work with certain
people
but i would never ask them to take me on
the road there were a few people
who did take me on the road with them
like todd jordan and rick kearns and
in my early career that they liked me
and then later on i had like uh
jimmy schubert when i came out here took
me on the road a few times and helped me
out and uh
who are support rodriguez in the in the
beginning you know
but i always knew
that i didn't want to be that guy i knew
that
i wanted to always be able to do my own
thing not just to sit at home and wait
for that beck and call
you know what i'm saying like that's the
type of person that i wanted to be
like i was still at the economy store i
mean and i was still
i did all those mexican rooms in south
la every single one of them every night
of the week
that's what paid for my addiction but at
the same time not knowing i was also
becoming a better comedian
because i would go into deep terrain
four nights a week
and then go to the comedy store
everything is hunky dory you follow me
you know there's there's places where
people come prepared to laugh and
there's places where it's a bar and you
gotta go up there
and blow your [ __ ] toe off to get
their attention it's like using the what
is it called the donut before when
you're swinging batting practice yeah
it's a little different you know it's
it's it's really weird to
and then you learn a fine line
you learn a fine line
after like five or six years of doing
that
you learn a fine line in between those
shows
and how different they are
and how different you have to walk down
the aisle of those shows
you can't do the bar material on stage
and you can't do a lot of the stage
material at a bar
would it be would it be hard for you to
do a uh a bar show now no no no no
bar shows are easier for me let me tell
you why
yes ready
it's 30 minutes
it's high energy
and filth
mixed with a little compassion
and just laying on them but it's got to
be high energy
so you stand out from everybody else and
you grab their attention
because of the bar the television is
going to be on
at a bar the pool table is going to be
[ __ ] people are going to still play
pool but that that sounds a lot like a
uh a comedy store set to me
no a company store is a contract a
controlled savage reset
it's a controlled set when i go to lose
lounge on a wednesday night because i
want to have three drinks and snort a
couple lines of blow
and also i get there and [ __ ] joe
diaz is on stage talking nonsense
it's a completely different night i
didn't come to listen to some guy
talking in my [ __ ] ear
right now i went there to [ __ ] get
drunk and do a couple lines and maybe
pick up some dirty chick that's there
so it's an hour and a half of that so
you have to convince me
that you're funny i have to have to
actually pay attention to you
so maybe a
a guy that's not as experienced goes up
first
he doesn't really do any damage because
it's a different environment than the
open mic per se
and even
the stage set
are you with me i'm with you i'm just
why do you think
that like it just seems like that would
be funny anyway why doesn't that uh uh
relate to like if you want like a comedy
club why doesn't it work okay because
when i go to a comedy club
you're paying to go in there and you're
prepared to laugh
that's the psychology of the game
when you go to an open mic half the
people aren't really drinking
they're frustrated comics just like you
doing material it's when you have a few
drinks that you loosen up on stage and
open mics do not get me wrong
are a lot of fun i always enjoyed open
mics
in the smaller cities
because it felt like the comics are
fighting for something
and i could take you back to three or
four cities
that i went and i personally saw growth
every four or five months because of
that certain open mic type pride in
those small cities
cities like houston texas cities like
austin
cities like boston
there's still small cities that you can
do comedy at
that it's
not as glamorous
but you get funny [ __ ] fast
be a lot faster than you would be in l.a
do you know why
because you get thrown into the lions a
lot faster
and they're different type of lions so
it's okay if you [ __ ] up in the back of
your mind the psychology of it
it's okay if you [ __ ] up in the back of
your mind
well it's interesting because you have a
different
judge every time you go on stage it's
not like the audience is the same
so that that that's actually something
that i haven't even thought about before
you can't even really it's hard to judge
your material because some material
works on some audiences and doesn't work
on others always but but it changes
every time you do a show so it's hard
that must be how hard to judge how your
material is doing
because you don't have a constant you
don't really have like a boss being like
oh yeah your work is getting better
you have to have someone come back and
be like oh yeah i saw you two weeks ago
well i know how i do once i get off
stage when i'm on stage i feel what they
feel uncomfortable
sometimes they're having a really good
time
energy is energy and what you give out
is what you get back
and you really learn that when you're on
a stage and people are in front of you
whether you're in a play whether you're
into music i can't imagine
playing the band like i did that thing
you know uh what's his name show with
you and i sang down there the goddamn
comedy jam right
that was a completely different animal
you know meat dog i overhand a lot
allies everything when i get stoned just
like anybody else and i thought about
that night and where that anxiety came
from
that anxiety [ __ ]
anybody would have got that
i thought that was [ __ ] like breaking
down because i got anxiety
anybody would have got that that's ever
been on stage before
it's the same anxiety you get
when you get on stage as a comedian
now i was singing which i had that meant
i had you know like people behind me
playing an instrument which is another
form of [ __ ]
you know like this another constant i
had never really had that yeah you never
had experience especially in front of
200 [ __ ] people whatever was in there
and i know you're an actor on a stand-up
and you have probably better
memorization than most people
but you did stand up that night too so
you have to do we have to remember your
stand up and you have to memorize a song
i didn't [ __ ] know you had to do a
story about the [ __ ] song oh but i
had no story about the song i just went
out there and [ __ ] around in front of
a bunch of
rock people
right i'm just saying memorizing a song
is tough okay a complete different
[ __ ] genre that's what jim florentine
is tremendous at
jim florentine goes to these rock bars
and rocks that [ __ ] world
you understand me something that i can't
i could do
but i don't do it often
i do more of comedy clubs
sometimes a theater
where you actually pay to [ __ ] come
see that specific [ __ ] comedian
at a rock club it's the same difference
but they're a little rowdy and plus
there's a constant they're standing
that makes the comedy a little tougher
right especially if you want to take it
into murky waters and go past the hour
do you think
but i mean like bands have different
kinds of like set like way they play the
songs because that's weird like to have
different kinds of ways you do stand up
isn't it is unique well
you know a band wants to change or maybe
they want to add a a cover to their
you know repertoire i i don't know i
don't do music right i know how comedy
changes i know that for me
i can't take let's say i had a set 45
minutes i was going to put on a [ __ ]
special
right i know
that there would be certain places where
i couldn't run that set
just because of what their thought
pattern is or just by me
thinking i know what their thought
pattern is
so it's a two-way street
but it generally works you know when it
works
when the energy is behind it when you
believe in your material that's where
your material works anywhere it could
work in hell
it could work in a christian church
it works anywhere when your belief
is a hundred percent that's what i've
learned
when i'm really loose
and i'm rocking them rolling that's it
that's it i believe in this material i
believe in what i'm [ __ ] saying
the story i'm telling you this is how it
went [ __ ] down i was [ __ ] there
my goal is to take you there
that is my goal as a comedian when i
bomb i know i failed that all those
[ __ ] aspects or one of those aspects
because there's possibly like it's like
when you sell something
if you go tomorrow and go joe diaz i
don't want to [ __ ] do podcasts no
more
and my uncle louie said he'd get me a
job selling uh what's hot now
pharmaceuticals sure or printers
printers
print
yeah sure everyone needs a printer all
right let's say you went and sold
[ __ ] printers right
you're gonna have your way of selling
but the company's gonna have you do
steps they're gonna send you oklahoma
for a week where you train
and the sales professionals there are
gonna show you you have steps on stage
believe it or not
you have steps
and if you don't [ __ ] believe me
watch two or three of the greatest the
people who i learned the steps one
number one
bill hicks
he walked you through steps
he planned those steps
even if it looked like improv it was all
planned
it wasn't improv
wow he was not improvising he was
setting you up
that's brilliance right there
number two
sam kennison
was setting you up
you up to eat your [ __ ] guts out
that's a different type
you know what i'm saying it's
it's weird
and then you had velvet hammers like
richard jenny what does velvet hammer
mean a velvet hammer exactly what i'm
saying
you don't see him coming
he just sucks you in
with a unique way of storytelling like
richard jenny those are the people who
taught me
that they had it planned out
there's sometimes i have a plan and it
still goes it still goes [ __ ] up and
then sometimes i don't have a plan
and the plan actually hatches right in
front of your [ __ ] eyes how's that
one for you [ __ ]
i don't know if it doesn't
does anyone have a plan i mean i know
some people do
but like even when you look like
sometimes i think whenever i hear about
these really influential people in
history i just think maybe like they
were just
they probably had shitty days and they
didn't know where they were going and
maybe they just came like maybe it just
happened i don't know
no and some part in some way they had
some sort of plan or
a belief or both
because before the plan can hatch you
have to have some sort of belief
in what in yourself yourself or whatever
[ __ ] you want to do
if you want to sell [ __ ] cameras
door-to-door
you have to have some type of belief
when you knock on that door why am i
providing you a [ __ ] service
why do you need to buy this from me
this is why i'm going to tell you why
you need to buy this camera from me
because of all these reasons
so you have a plan
and after a while but you keep doing it
that plan you'll see the catches of your
plan
where you hook people you know what i'm
saying with certain words and stuff like
you start seeing what people respond to
yeah and also you start taking pauses
because when you're selling something
like that pause is a number one because
it shows that you have control
of the conversation okay
you know when i sold i learned a lot
i've talked about this on this show a
thousand times
i give that a lot of credit
to why we're doing what we're doing now
because they came apart where i became a
business
instead of just a regular comedian
there's two different mindsets but to
get that mindset you have to have a
belief and to have that belief you got
to cover that spread you gotta do the
[ __ ] work
but
there are some we've we've talked to
like
how you did you you weren't ready for
jeff getlin
at that point did you think you were
like did you think you'd put in the work
i had been doing comedy seven years at
that time
i didn't know dick about dick
i got here when i was doing comedy
let's face it honestly
i got here when i was doing comedy six
years
as a as a individual comic
i was a mediocre feature act when i
moved here
no acting experience except a college
film
at the university of colorado
that's it no acting classes
didn't even know about that world i
liked movies
but did you did you think in your head
at that time were you saying oh i'm
gonna i'm a star i'm the best comic
coming to l.a are you you were
reasonable with yourself no no not at
all not at all
when i saw pablo francisco do seinfeld
in spanish
i knew i sucked
when i saw doug's manhole
destroy
the comedy store at 8 30 one night i
knew i sucked
when i saw joe rogan destroy i met a
medron one night it was an hour set that
till this night i'll never forget the
reaction of people in the room that's
when rogan was broken 1998
99 he was uninhibited he had worked this
set like a year and a half
two years he hadn't gone on the road
with this
and it was pinpoint
and one night he unleashed it you know i
still remember those early performances
how i saw
i was like wow i'm far away from this
[ __ ]
i remember seeing greg geraldo and
seeing [ __ ]
earthquake one night at the laugh
factory
basically take the wall paint off the
[ __ ] wall
and it wasn't a black knight it was a
white knight
all right you know you see these comics
and you go jesus
what the [ __ ] did they just do well how
many comics do you think are realistic
with themselves or how many do you think
are like oh i could do that
i'm that funny
at that point i did not think that well
right i know i didn't strictly be honest
at that point i was doing comedy maybe
eight years when you round it all up
2000 2001
that was 10 years by that point
i had been in la four years and i had
seen some great
[ __ ] sets you know i saw some great
sets i saw a comic one night lou torres
on a thursday night take the original
room apart
he did some comics and he did some jokes
he did some impersonations
and then he sang and i'll never forget
this
there was a black dude that i met in
seattle
i can't remember what his name was he
wore a little hat he was very good to me
he was very nice to me and josh wolfe
one night in seattle he was on a tv show
he was the musical director
okay on a show on abc
the stephanie something show
and he wore a hat he was a black dude
and
he was on this show at abc and me and
lee me and josh wolf
or feature an emcee that weekend
we got on that weekend on purpose
because we knew the place would be
packed
i never believed that working with the
guy would make me a star do you know
what i'm saying right yeah i would cheat
my way through anything like that
it just so happened the guy was crazy
he read the jaguar and [ __ ]
and he asked us friday night what are
you guys going to do like nothing
we'll [ __ ] feature axe he goes come
with me let's go to a strip club
he took us two towns over
we went to a strip club i got like one
lap dance and i had a bag of blow
i'd take a cab home it was [ __ ]
horrible the next night he took us out
again well guess what three months later
i'm in l.a i didn't know i was gonna
move to la
and he was at the store every day
it's crazy how you meet people on the
road before you [ __ ] movie
you always have to be nice
what the [ __ ] is his name now it's gonna
want me
now the show got cancelled
he still did spots but i remember seeing
him one night at the improv
on a saturday night
he sang he'd crack jokes
and he played the piano
he [ __ ]
that room
up
so my point is when i saw those people
do those things
i thought i was years away realistically
i could be honest with you
i thought one night i was in the main
room and i saw paul rodriguez destroy
that room
and mitzy sure told me something that
night that stuck with me so i knew
and she goes you see that that's 20
years
at that time i was doing comedy maybe
eight years i was like [ __ ]
20 [ __ ] years
but you know what i never thought about
it
i never said i'm going to stick it out
to 20 years i just didn't think about it
that way
i just was happy i was doing it that day
that's the crazy i was happy i was doing
it that [ __ ] day
if you do anything for 20 years you have
to be
it's like at least
pretty good at it like that i can't even
imagine doing something for 20 years
neither could i at least i had
neither could i that's why i didn't give
a thought
when i was at the eight year mark i was
like
this is gonna end any day now
because yeah i got on stage the first
time in 91 okay of july so or june one
of those two
so by [ __ ] 2000 i'm like oh this is
gonna [ __ ]
this outside was gonna happen i'm gonna
get hit in the head with a building or
some [ __ ] so that sounds like you're
listening to my brain now oh my god i
got the ten year anniversary
and i was like this is crazy
i hit the ten year anniversary i had a
girlfriend we were poor
but we had an apartment we had one car
and it worked i was doing blow it worked
and you know what by like the 11th year
i was doing tv
and trust me i would walk out of those
auditions
in shock
like i signed with jeff in 98
i started clicking in 2001.
yeah over those three years there was
individual things and
bing bang boom an hour on this game show
or something like that
but theatrically i didn't start clicking
until 2001
2002
2003 and i think jeff left
he became a producer in 2002.
i i stayed with nancy act
you follow me so i lost the manager but
i called her up right away
because i knew that was as good as like
i when i went and met with them
when we walked out of there i'm like i'm
not signing with her
you're crazy that's a haunted house
there were pictures on the wall and
[ __ ]
coffee cups
it looked like bruce willis office and
that [ __ ] movie there were damon
wayans
well it was paperwork everywhere that
was her office
but
she's like dawg all my people work
all my [ __ ] people work joey and i'm
like okay
whatever i walked out there like [ __ ]
you
i'm never he's like you gotta sign what
i'm telling you so when he left i went
right to her
because i knew one thing i would get out
there
for auditions at least for auditions at
least
holy [ __ ]
pretty [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
but what i was telling you is that what
i was trying to tell you it
that even when i met joe i met joe on on
a very innocent level
when i met joe i didn't know what news
radio was
i could tell you honestly i did have at
that time i didn't watch tv i was so
focused on stand-up
i didn't i couldn't tell you what was on
tv
if it wasn't on after one or two in the
morning on hbo or one of those channels
i had no idea what tv was
in the daytime i was usually working or
sleeping or coming down off coke or
there was no tv in my life when i got
into comedy so when i met joe when i met
you know at that time there was a bunch
of people hanging out at the store
andrew was there every night
you know i didn't talk to andrew for
maybe
two two and a half years three years
when i was at the store i just didn't
think i had a right to go up to him and
talk to him if he wanted to talk to me
let him [ __ ] talk to me and i'll talk
back to him that's how i was raised i
wouldn't oh yeah absolutely gary
shandling was still going to the store
who's the guy that blows up the balloon
we're still going up to the store lenny
clark was going up to the [ __ ] store
it was a bunch of [ __ ] people going
up to the store in those days
so both of those brothers were going up
to the store the weigh-ins were at the
store every [ __ ] night and those in
those days there was damon
and the brother who was the the director
of [ __ ] and living color
they would come out together every
[ __ ] night
and one would do a set and then the
other guy would do a set
you know there was a ton of people that
i used to say hello to
i would have mild conversations with
them hello goodbye are you up next yeah
how do you like going up late you know
[ __ ] like that they would just talk to
me about that type of [ __ ]
but for some reason i never thought
honestly
that me
asking them
like the only thing they could do
that anybody could do is give me advice
and i had god rest his soul i had rick
dukeman in those days who i really
believed in
and i kind of wanted a career like his
what was his career like he would do a
few movies a year
he would do a few weekends on the road
he had a wife and he had children
and he kept it simple
you know
he was in a few movies it was a few
times hank movies
and whenever i would have a problem in
those days i would call him
and he would sort it out for me i think
that's i was going to ask you about that
i think that's hugely important
because
we were talking about it earlier how
like you can
convince yourself of something convince
yourself that you're not good or
convinced yourself something's going to
end
and i think
how how long did you have him as like a
sounding board
i met him in seattle in 97 96
and we stayed in touch mutually through
a friend this was way before
uh
social media you know i was involved
i didn't get involved with a
a hotmail until 98 99
and i i forgot all about my [ __ ]
hotmail and the code and [ __ ] i just
remember i had a hotmail like 2001
when i needed a [ __ ] email that
seriously i didn't know nothing about a
computer or nothing
and then when i got to la
i never wanted to ask
our mutual friend
for dukeman's number
so what i did was i had spots at the
store
and he would have spots at the store he
would go up down the weekends he would
do the laugh factory the improv
then his wife and him would close it up
at the store he'd smoke a number out
there with the guys and stuff like that
and i'd see him
and one day he offered me his number and
he goes if you need any help
when you're here call me
so
i didn't want to ask him to be a regular
at the store because i had stanhope
i had called those mencia vouch for me i
had that kid uh
the black kid from seattle vouched for
me the one i just told you with that
stuff
i had a few people vouch me in those
days
and
i got a call and
i became a regular
i i kept brick duke him in to the side
rick went on the road in those days but
very subtly
especially to canada
so in those days i could get into canada
i never asked him you know i never even
brought it up with him
but what would happen is
for some reason we would get spots on
the same night
so i would have his ear
for 10 or 15 [ __ ] minutes
but every time he saw me i made sure i
approached him
with something
like i had advanced
you know and it was weird we had a few
conversations
and i had a few conversations with his
wife
and this those conversations still
[ __ ] i still remember those
conversations about how to act
how to
go over the top and not go over the top
just
in movies in general because he had done
all those movies
and at first i would go to acting
lessons but if i had a producer session
i would call him
and he told me exactly what to do and i
do it exactly to the t
so a lot of the [ __ ] i do for auditions
today
is because rest in peace because of rick
duke
and then they work dude like you find do
you feel fine when you straight from
what he told you like you [ __ ] up and
then if you try what he said it works
well he would navigate me on every move
like when i got the pilot he told me
what to do next
you know he was an old school hustler so
he would tell me to go to that [ __ ]
bookstore
and buy the casting director book
and get the address to the top ten
casting directors and hand delivering
them an envelope with a resume and a
handwritten [ __ ] letter
and i did that to the t and guess what
my auditions went up 30 [ __ ] percent
now did they go up 30 because
they read the envelopes ah maybe
it went up 30 because i put 30 more
percent effort in
and that's what he used to always tell
me you have to work it from every
[ __ ] angle
then i figured out from him telling me
that we're casting directors
i figured out if you buy that [ __ ] uh
back stage west on wednesdays
you get auditions from that
in the beginning i didn't have a [ __ ]
age at least all those auditions i was
getting
were auditions that i was generating and
even though i was blowing them
like i was completely wrong at all
like there weren't years i didn't book
anything that's the honest [ __ ]
i don't even think i used to get call
backs back then that's how bad i was
but
by going into all those rooms and
getting it out of the way
they weren't big projects
they were all going to be [ __ ] sacks
of [ __ ] anyway in the long run i never
saw one of those things getting played
out or they probably went to a small
festival or something they weren't going
to change my life right but all those
auditions i went through
got me ready for [ __ ]
it was like three years of auditioning
to get it finally down to wow this is
how i have to do it
i took acting lessons and i mixed it
together
but i would call rick for different
things like that
he was like a mentor to me till about
2004 and then
i didn't hear from him for a while
he went back to canada
and guess what what happened i booked
the longest yard
[ __ ]
and i and i didn't call him
and i booked the longest yard like i
think i left him a message on his phone
and that was the end of that i never
heard from him again all right
and guess what
what the longest yard
gets released
on like a wednesday night
here
like and i don't know nothing about this
[ __ ] they don't tell me
i don't want people at home to think
there's a premiere
there's usually a cast and crew let's
pretend
there's a cast and crew on monday night
and it would be over by century city
where we did doug
okay right there okay that's where the
cast and crew there's a movie theater
there
right there so it's not as big as
glamorous no okay no that's for cast and
crew you can bring your wife
let's say you're the camera dude you can
bring paula okay i gotcha
all right so then tuesday
they take it over to hollywood boulevard
and they do the glam bam
the red carpet the stars tuesday
wednesday right
and then
wednesday
they watch at oprah's house
did you know that
that's how every movie gets released now
this is oh okay this is what i was going
to say i was when spider-man 2 came out
this new longest yard came out you know
chris rock was friends with oprah
sam raimi was friends with oprah makes
more sense so i heard and i didn't dog
that i got no dog please i don't want
nobody no nobody invites uncle joey
those things at all uncle joey hears
about this [ __ ] years later
and that's how i figured this out
then thursday they have a screening at
the studio
for regular if steven spielberg wants to
come
[ __ ] okay they serve whatever some food
you go you mingle you got to be jewish
to get in there like nothing else gets
in there
98.3 percent of jews
one guy slips in there because you know
he wants to let money on the bank for
the one dude
something
like that there's one black guy one
asian guy
and that night
something must have happened
the movie got released friday
and that friday night i'm in houston
texas
i was in houston for the weekend for a
purpose
because i did well in houston
and the houston uh
football team was doing like a mini camp
i knew this because the comedy club
owned his wife
worked for pepsi
so she knew everything that was going on
with sports in the area
and they would do some type of things so
she had them
go to the movies with me
oh [ __ ] she set that up too were they
the oilers in or were they the texans
the texas they're still there the texas
they went to texas so she set that up i
didn't know nothing about these viewings
and nothing like that i didn't know how
it worked i would be lying to you if i
knew i knew nothing
i'm in houston texas
so i'm basically in houston getting
[ __ ] up
i barely made it to this movie with the
texans
then that friday i had the radio so that
night
the shows were packed
for a person it wasn't a well-known
comic i did really well in houston then
this is 2005. okay
so
had they seen the movie by that at that
point do you think a lot of people went
to the segment like this late movie was
packed and then sadly it was dripping
from the [ __ ] themes oh my god
but i'll never forget that that friday
night i'm doing a couple lines of coke
it's about one in the morning houston
time
which would make it eleven o'clock in
l.a
right right right yeah and these days
they used to close the comedy club
and you could set the bar with the
owners and a bunch of guys that would be
in a couple you know they have like 30
people they don't get me wrong
some people were drinking some people in
there drinking and smoking
and there were some people like myself
that were [ __ ] filthy animals
and we'd be going to the bathroom and
doing bumps and drinking jagermeister
and beers and [ __ ] and getting [ __ ] up
old school texas
and all of a sudden one night guess what
my phone rang
it was about 11 15 11 30 at night it was
really do coming oh
and he goes what's up
and it was like an unknown number
or something yeah it was blocked but it
was blocked because it was called out of
the country ah and he goes how you doing
congratulations i went to work my kid he
goes listen
i just want you to know something
monday when you get in call me because i
want to set something up with you tom
hank wants to meet you
that's one of the last times i talked to
him doug
he said a meeting of a me and tom hanks
that was it
and then
i talked to him once after that and then
recently i heard he passed away maybe a
few years ago
but he was sort of like
the guy in the beginning
that talked me through things he helped
me make little moves would you be like
should i do this club should i take this
deal yes
he became and once he knew i was serious
he got more into it
it wasn't because i was slipping him
like i was making
calculated moves even then
like i was here for maybe a year and i
popped that taco bell commercial
that taco bell commercial was huge
it was everywhere did they see me
for a split second if you had a [ __ ]
eagle eye
and contact lenses binoculars and a
nassau telescope that's the only way you
could see me in this commercial but
guess what
way before the computer i told everybody
at that store
and then people come up to me i saw you
and i saw you
so it was really
crazy i you'd have to be [ __ ] that
fast to see me in this [ __ ] thing
but that was the first thing i booked i
shot the pilot for cbs
and then i popped basketball
so this was
i remember still auditioning for
basketball
calling him afterwards
and going you're not going to believe
what happened
i just auditioned for basketball and he
goes listen if you get that movie
that's going to be good for you where's
tony bennett
it's monday [ __ ]
that we were strong tonight
yes it was
the store seem to be doing okay
somebody
anyway let me give a [ __ ] couple
shots out of here my man joey zaza
tweets thank you for the candles
one's shaking the devil's hand and
selling his soul i had a [ __ ] light
that one on fire with the chicken blood
and [ __ ] you [ __ ]
anyway thank you for the candles
my man david garner my man matt
balthazar my little black sabbath
[ __ ] goomba what i'm gonna see in
[ __ ] wise guys in utah in a few weeks
sam
femino
michael j brannon
jamie mclaughlin zant my man zach gibbs
with the [ __ ] picture of his [ __ ]
aaron hernandez there
happy jay
happy birthday my man
j [ __ ]
aka johnny pittsburgh
a.k.a manny godzilla manny sanguine you
know i love you jay i'll see you in
september
and my other main man
d
ferretti what are you kidding me or what
20 to the life no parole you understand
me at least saying what's going on
coxswain i'm facing tomorrow's a weird
day for me as always is this year
it didn't bother me i'm not gonna sit
here and think i need to go see a
psychiatrist or nothing
i got those type of little problems like
that how many stars eat lately
uh ten i think you should lay fifteen
i'm sorry like it's no longer i'm too
cold here to me what are you gonna do
don't you to apologize to me you know i
still love you either way
it's
i bust your balls like i bossed your
balls a lot because
there's a lot of nights
i actually go there and way before i
went to see the hypnotist
i gotta be honest with you you know i
lied
way before i went to see the hypnotist
i was hypnotizing myself in a way
because i wanted to go home at night
if you
listen man there's no [ __ ] fountain
of youth
your body's your body your hearts your
heart
things happen along the way you know you
don't know what's gonna happen with your
heart or
if you smoke the wrong [ __ ] cigarette
that one time that they put the extra
contamination in
you don't [ __ ] know every day is a
[ __ ] windy road with my luck i did no
you didn't
but anyway the point being what the [ __ ]
is the point in me
see you you make me feel like you're
gonna find my views tomorrow's a hard
day you bust my balls
yeah and some nights i would go home at
night
and you know i hate the stars like you
i i did what you did and sometimes not
in my office
but i go in my living room i turn off
the tv
and i put the chair thing under my legs
i would just close my eyes and i would
take myself back
to what i felt like when i was your age
like as dumb as this sounds people
you know
i would just sit there at night close my
eyes and go what the [ __ ]
did i feel like
when i was 28 [ __ ] years old
and it's
right now my feet
from how high my blood pressure went up
i could feel my body throbbing under my
leg that's
how i felt at 28 like my fingers
like i was hypnotizing myself
without [ __ ] knowing it were you
angry
why was your blood pressure going up
because i think about the person that i
was at that age
and i was just a cased animal
looking for trouble
without knowing like and i had just come
out of jail
you know but i was still not doing what
i was doing before there was no weapons
there was nothing like that
i was just basically
91 is when i got on stage the first time
91 is when i
the year started me really wanting to be
a good estimator
so i went to seminars and did all that
[ __ ] on my own
and
by the same time i wanted to do stand-up
so 91 i was 28 i was getting married no
19.
i started comedy
but while i was starting comedy i got to
be honest here
i didn't know what direction i was going
with my wife and the kid
and four months later we got separated
that was over
so at your age already i had been out of
prison
that's crazy i started stand up
and i had gotten divorced
and i sit there and just thinking about
that
makes my [ __ ] heart beat
and my fingers drop for a few reasons
there's a few reasons there
it reminds me of what i felt like
when i realized
i was gonna be able to do comedy for
real
that was a [ __ ] up feeling to have
you had it early on and doing comedy no
no no no no
when i was when i [ __ ] got look at
you smee just me telling you that right
now
my eyeball i just lost 10 [ __ ] pounds
on myself
really listen man
you have no idea what it is
to do something
fall in love with it have a certain
feeling about it
and know this is what you want to do
and you got to figure out a way to do it
and one day you walk in the door and
somebody [ __ ] tells you
here you go you want to do comedy here
it is
like for a month i was in shock
yeah i was in shock i was getting
separated
yeah i was in shock i was seeing my
daughter but i was in shock
that the answer i was looking for was
laid out in front of me
like i wasn't [ __ ] shockedly
like i kept thinking how am i gonna do
stand up and make this work
well now i lost my job with them
you know i was off probation
i could leave the state
i had a nice car i had a little savings
if this if i was going to do stand them
this was the time to do it
you know what we're going to sell the
condo anyway
i'll get myself a little partly south
bold
no part of you thought
let me get an apartment and i'll get a
job
and maybe this comedy thing isn't for me
i wanted to give it an old [ __ ]
yankee try
if that's the expression
it should be i wanted to
just try it for a while
just to see i didn't want to go
overboard
i wasn't thinking about nothing big
nothing nothing like that i didn't start
thinking about craziness until about
nine months in
about nine months to ten months animals
i started thinking craziness what does
that mean what is craziness craziness
means that you know what
i don't know what these [ __ ]
old batted comics are talking about kind
of what i look like right now what i'm
telling you
like i would i would i was [ __ ] uh
at this point i'm maybe
29 maybe turning 30. i'm about 29 by
this point
and i had been i had been the house mc
at the broker for a year
so once a month i would get a different
comic
and there were great comics doug
stanhope was one i've mentioned this
before i mean there were
too many to to remember
some of them still do comedy some people
are comedy writers now
some people have moved on you know it's
pretty interesting the people i opened
up for
and it was always a two show
you know two comics it was a feature
and a headline and the features were
usually from anywhere from oregon
to seattle to northern california
they could be from chicago it was
[ __ ] crazy so you meant two new
comics every week every every once uh
yeah every tuesday what am i saying once
a month
every tuesday no no no no
hold on
yeah every tuesday every tuesday i'm in
a different comic for a year and a half
that that's your college course but
by about the seventh or eighth month
i had already made the decision i was
like you know what
these guys they don't know what they're
doing
oh yeah i had already made a decision
like i started in july of 91
and by december
of 92 i had a solution to all my
problems
hit me with it you want me to drop it on
you i would love it all right my
solution was to move to new york city
was a good start and do comedy in
manhattan
and that jay leno would walk into the
club one night
and i would be on stage doing stand-up
and he would talk me off the stage and
tell me to be on a tonight show a week
later
how many times a day did you fantasize
about this happening 200 times a day
and it could have been him or leatherman
or
uh what's the guy who just died the
little jewish guy mickey rickles what's
his name
oh my god i call them
that earthquake weed is good no i
thought oh yeah that's quick week that's
hallucinogenic type [ __ ] there that's
the real deal
all you guys are going out of the jungle
the [ __ ] see jesus
you're wasting playing for it
come over here smoke this death with
uncle joey don't get beat up on united
oh my god no no no
no i did not know
i had no [ __ ] ideally look at the
shape of you look at the shape of me
oh man
another thing that i was thinking about
tomorrow
i called my friend today i have like
three friends tomorrow that's their
birthday you know anybody tomorrow 21st
day birthday i check facebook but i
don't think no please i don't need for
you to just pray if you don't know them
off the top of your [ __ ] head
okay you know anyone i know my mom's
birthday my dad's birthday
i know three people that are having
birthdays
so
guys i'm sorry just uh just
uh um
why is tomorrow a hard day for you about
thinking about why what it was like when
you're 28
oh no you i was telling you that this
sometimes i just go home and think
of what i'm like at your age right
i don't think i was any hungrier than
you were
i think um
i wasn't as confused as you were i was
going to start a new business every week
and getting business guides you should
how many business cards would be given
away no no none one zero i had them on
the sheet and it was just me and him
so i gave a one away one card
yeah i feel very i feel i feel it's
interesting
uh my
ten year high school reunions right
after thanksgiving
and i feel more
unsure
and confused now
than i did when i was 18 going to
college
what are you afraid of you're going to
go back and your friend's a doctor isn't
it no i can't i'm not going back and i
just can't go back i'm not going back
for thanksgiving listen that's the worst
time to fly i'll tell you what i'll do
let's get you a nice suit let's take you
like a [ __ ] gold chain
with a yarmulke star
like one of those jewish stars
can i get the the yamaha they've always
talked about with the blood diamond no
no yeah because you're gonna go up there
looking good nice and bald and cute
you're gonna give yourself a little
[ __ ] goal you're gonna lose 40 pounds
you're gonna go see the mexican doctor
i'm gonna shoot you with a couple
[ __ ]
mexican illegal drugs
you walk in there looking like [ __ ]
main street charlie [ __ ] yolk to the
gills
and you go to your high school reunion
ten years and you lie to people what do
you give a [ __ ] they're gonna be lying
to you they all just got out of jail
they don't just [ __ ] lie about i mean
most of them i mean most of them stayed
in massachusetts it's fine they're doing
great mother
richard how many of those people have
you kept in touch with
and not since
many people when you're graduating class
dad three or four hundred i think yeah
you were regular [ __ ] jump until joy
once yeah yeah no i don't know i don't
people don't i don't know people don't
like me who knows no people no i don't
know i'm a nice guy
no but uh
if i win i'm sure i'd have fun but it
just it's just a weird feeling i felt so
so sure at 18 and at 28 now i'm
it's not that i'm unsure it's just
unsure about lisa
it's it's not even
unsure isn't isn't uh the right word for
it i have so there's so many
opportunities right now it's that's what
i'm like i'm not good at the cheesecake
factory because there's 8 000 pages and
everything looks good and i can't make a
decision
so what do you want to do i
i i love podcasts it's definitely going
to be in podcast
it's just uh
and it's not even it's not even like
what i want to do it's like like it's as
you as you've talked about hopefully at
some point
someone's starting something so
if it's for uh tv shows that could be
it's just there's so many different ways
podcast could be used
it's uh
it's a little overwhelming sometimes
well let me tell you something i'm 54
year old
i'm still [ __ ] confused yeah so
that's so trustworthy doesn't make me
feel any better it never goes away
because if you have any kind of
heartbeat
as fast as fast as technology's moving
and all the things that are happening
because it's fast you have to if you're
a ceo of any company
of any company
you have to always look at these things
how fast this is moving if there's a
writer's strike
where are you remembering we saw 96
today 96 where you would be putting your
ads
you know these are all things that uh
right now with all the technology you
don't know what's going gonna happen and
that's
and that's the scariest part because
even with youtube people are getting
really mad at youtube right now because
they've changed their whole ad structure
and
there's
like there's been so many
podcast networks that have come and gone
in life since we've started
and
you have to think that when they're
in their first meetings and they're
setting up and they have the talent
they all were just as or more motivated
and excited than as i am
so but it
it's it's when you see so many people
failing
it's it's daunting i'll tell you what
man
it was very appealing starting a network
right there was a while there when we
spoke about it and it was very appealing
but i knew one thing
i knew that
i'm not the most affluent person in the
world i know that
i'm not the most charming person in the
world i know there's a certain taste
and you know what if i'm going to focus
on something let me focus on what's in
front of me
which is the podcast i always wanted to
be consistent
and i always didn't have to worry about
anything the last thing i need to do is
show up here
on monday and wednesday and the camera's
broken and there's spaghetti on the
[ __ ] table
and there's a rat in the [ __ ] garbage
and i see a condom in there i don't want
to share a studio with anybody right no
i never wanted to do anything that was
part of the freedom that i wanted
you know what there's times i said here
that maybe i should belong to a park
podcast network and why don't i and
whatever
you know what man
i think i've thrown out of the boy
scouts and i learned my [ __ ] lesson
i could lie to you and tell you i was in
a street gang i was never in a [ __ ]
street gang
you know when i i knew kids who hung out
at 148th street that said
i would i did never nothing organized
like that except play basketball
and some football i didn't know anything
ever before like that and i don't want
to know it
right i didn't want to be a part of
something like that i rather enjoy what
we're doing right now oh yeah and that's
the thing
i'm not itching to get out it's just
you and i talk about it a lot that's
what we talk about
after the thing and
just the uh because maybe what you're
saying is i should be looking at
the people like the the all things
comedy and the and the podcast ones and
the people who have succeeded
and instead of
focusing on the ones who failed
well the ones that succeeded
didn't i tell you why primarily
because somewhere on there they had an
experienced
there's somebody who
a lot of those guys tried to switch from
radio to podcasting right i'd say it's
two different forms
it's two different formats
and people are ready for a change
you understand when i'm trying to go
with this right and then and so a lot of
people were left like dinosaurs
there's limited amount of radio in these
markets where i go to it's not like
where i could go into a town and do a
radio for three days
how many how many like out of ten
do you do radio now
out of 10 city yeah
usually i usually do
a radio in every city okay but it's one
morning
it's uh
8 30 a.m and 9 45 and we're done for the
day
it used to be
8 30 9 45 11 50
2 30
and maybe a 3 40 call it
well that's a lot those days are done
anymore
unless you're rosie or donald or
somebody like that
you know they put out a press release
and they call back for them
you know
but to answer your question we let me
tell you something
i don't think there comes an age when
you're not confused
and unsure even a little bit
even as you're depositing the check in
the [ __ ] bank that's that's all i'm
working towards that only yeah i don't
know in my hand all i want do you want a
structured life i mean what is it that
you do no no
because i don't necessarily need a
structured life
i would like
i would like to be able to
have well my goals used to be all money
related so that's right that's my my
mind first one right now but in reality
the past few years i've had a very
i've lived three miles from the the
studio
i do i do a few podcasts a week
but i have a lot more freedom with my
day than i had when i was at an office
listen to me forget all that nonsense
okay the beauty about this podcast was
the beauty about this podcast and how i
knew this podcast was going to work was
how anything works in this life you have
to
love it for free
if you can't get up and do something for
free
do not [ __ ] do it
i'm talking about if i call you up you
know what remember when i you know those
movies
i did with the dog
all those movies those companies that
did those movies were a little
buggaloosh
if you know what i mean
and
the second movie i did with them there
were certain people who were not getting
paid
as a matter of fact the guys who would
you know picking up cameras and moving
them and polishing and
setting them up and setting the cameras
and putting the color in the room and
all that
there was a lot of those dudes that were
not getting paid
they were doing this for five weeks for
free
just to get experience
yeah yeah somebody put them together to
do this in many ways i agree with the
concept
but in many ways i didn't
you want to not pay him i could see that
paying for three weeks
but pay him anything after [ __ ] six
hours you know what i'm saying
they were working these [ __ ] 12
hours
they you're willing to do that when you
first come out when you come out here
it's but it's
i'm sure i'm sure you now you're a
little bit jaded and now it's uh
no no i'm not jaded
i just understand the concept now i've
worked on bigfoot remember lee let's get
something straight
beside grudge match
the last big film i worked on was
somewhere after the longest yard
i'm talking about where people open up
the door for you
i'm talking about when you go to
wardrobe three weeks before
i'm talking about where
they take you shopping
if i analyze that i met them at wardrobe
and they took me to like [ __ ] in
midtown manhattan the men's big and
small the shirt was two g's
the shirt alone was two [ __ ] jesus
did i try to go with a 2 000 shirt just
for the shirt the leather jacket that'll
be jesus god knows how much it was that
soft leather that looked like
paper thin and weighed nothing
that jacket was i forget what the [ __ ]
that was
they took me shopping
next thing you know
whatever happens happens
and i'm doing these 100 a day movies
where you bring your own [ __ ] clothes
so i've done all the movies at every
level if you look at my mdb
there's some big movies but there's also
a lot of small movies
you know for a while there i wanted to
get good that i was doing
so i'd work with you you know what i'm
saying
work with you a little bit who gives a
[ __ ] if you [ __ ] up on scared tactics
you can't [ __ ] up it's improvised
this is that that's fine it's funny
you're talking about this i actually
wrote this down so when do you when did
he stop taking those roles like the
roles that
the 100 day movies the the the tv shows
maybe you after i did 25 of them
and i came to a conclusion
you know the girl that did the movie
with clint eastwood as a boxer girl yes
okay you know that movie i i don't think
if it's that movie
i think it's the movie that cleaves
would see her saw her in to put her in
that movie
was a 100 day movie
when you when they book you in those
movies they always tell you the concept
that they have an out
and you're gonna
be seen
and there was a lot of those films i did
that on paper
looked great until i got to the set
and i was like oh [ __ ]
there's a few movies i did that i think
are great
but nobody ever seen
why
the company dropped the ball
you'll see it ten years from now late
night at three in the morning
on some [ __ ] up channel
as part of their [ __ ] thing there's
something like that in 2000 that still
runs on there used to be a gay channel
logo logo it ran on there once or twice
a [ __ ] month
i'm not gonna tell you the name of it i
don't want people to know any [ __ ]
because the the director of it and the
producer the writer were gay
so they wrote this script
so they sold it to different so you
never
know what you're doing but a lot of
things
the reason to answer your question the
reason why i stopped doing the all-day
movies because they were getting me
nowhere
that's the honest to god bottom line
but
i don't want somebody else to get that
mindset
i also did 20 of them
can i go on my mdb with you right now
and count them out for you
i guarantee it's a lot closer to 20 than
that
the six basket the six dog movies i did
we're all damn always
with dean kane
those are all
day movies wow
okay i could name
if i look at my mdb there was a time of
redemption all those movies 100 hours a
day
you bring your own wardrobe
you better bring water just in case
you know
there's no
there's no guy with wardrobe bringing
your wardrobe to your room
when you do a movie for cbs when you get
there the wardrobe's in your room and
[ __ ]
you know you go to makeup they tune you
up no no no no no
and this these [ __ ] movies it's a
chick standing there
and she'll come next to you and touch
you up a little bit and that's it
[ __ ]
what's two different worlds what's the
comedy equivalent to a 100 day movie
like a b club or featuring or like when
did he stop doing that
when i elevated myself
remember i elevated myself the headline
in 2005 officially
before that i co-headlined
i featured if i had to to make ends meet
but i was starting the headline now
when i navigated my way into headliner
was i a headliner
no
i navigated my way into a headliner how
i planned i would
by doing movies and tv
the longest yard was my launch pad
after that i booked myself as a
headliner
period
all those clubs i had featured for
i called them with a different [ __ ]
attitude now
even though they hadn't seen you do an
hour you were just like
i did this movie i've been at your club
four times already
i've blown your headliner out let's lift
a rock
troy what are you talking about
yeah come on
they would hit me with a number that was
so lowly
with no plane ticket and i would bump
them a little bit and get a plane ticket
out of them
and then you know what
let's pretend 300 people paid just
because of the longest yard
that's more than a lot of people believe
that
yeah you have 52 weeks and then are
those sort of clubs like are there be
i'm sure there are there was a couple
clubs i did really well one time dallas
improv
houston laptop
it was somewhere else that even in 2005
i was starting to build a little bit of
an audience
new jersey
no but then you drift away
you
you get away from that i started doing
movies i got a girlfriend
the one club closed down
the other club lost its management
the management i was used to
you know things happened things evolved
so now
you evolve from one club to another it's
usually not because of my loyalty if you
take care of me back then
i'm still with you
i was with people towards the end so i'm
one of those guys
but today clubs open up a new one opens
some of the old timers moved on you know
so you can't really be as loyal to the
clubs anymore no i'm still law you know
well yeah i love certain clubs there's
certain clubs that even today
i wouldn't dream of going anywhere else
even what the agents tell me
i could name like six of them off the
bat that i wouldn't leave i love
i don't want to do a theater i'd rather
just stay there
you know but just how i hypnotize myself
to think about being 28 just to see
where your head is at
no disrespect to you just to say jesus
christ
what was i thinking at 28 like i was
already married
i wasn't really thinking about banging
her anymore we already had the kid
it was brutal and i'm working 40 hours a
week
and once i got on stage i really wanted
to do it
but
before i was thinking about that today's
one of my i told you today i have three
friends of the birthdays tomorrow
so one of them i sent the card to
the other one me and her are not going
to seek themselves that much anymore
so i'll wait till i feel tomorrow and
see if i just send her a message on
facebook
and then the one is a close close friend
of mine that i love daily
so i made a point to call it today you
know just to get it out of the way
before tomorrow
and she caught back around the time i
went outside and i what's up
and we just spoke for a few minutes and
i was like happy birthday i just want to
get you today because i know you're
probably she because you were right
i'm going to do this thing and the
reception's bad down there me and my
husband
so at one point she's like jesus christ
we're getting old joey you know she
calls me coco still and
i was like i know i know i know you know
as soon as i went to my cousin's wedding
blah blah blah
my dad 10 years ago was doing something
and now he can't do it no more because
of his knee you know just
we're just talking generalities
and she goes i'll tell you something
you know you always call me on my
birthday
and i was like i i remember that day
that's easy
and she goes why because you love me i
go that but
it's the day i left new jersey the first
time
and she just was like
oh my god i still remember that night
like yeah we were friends
we were tight friends even back then
she hung out at that bar
that i used to hang out and i used to
borrow money from the [ __ ] loan shark
there
you gonna go on a white party that night
no i had never told anybody i was going
away
so why does she remember that night
because i told her
like two nights before
so you guys were really close okay
we were close
but as that time came
we were starting to get closer
we hung out in the same clique
and we liked chinese food
and we would go to white castle at night
and we giggled and she had a boyfriend
and i had whatever i had going on
but i kind of took an interest and we
became friends we kept it at that
so
then two nights before i left it was
like a
like a tuesday i saw her out
and i pulled her out so i'm like listen
do me a favor
don't say nothing to nobody she was cool
like i'm going to colorado
with jimmy berkel
you won't worry about her writing you
out or people finding you no
i trust her that much man
i trust her that much at that time i
knew that even if she said something
nobody was going to take a helicopter to
colorado don't get me
nobody was taking a plane to colorado
when you said the word colorado those
people in those days you might as well
tell them [ __ ] jupiter
it's the same distance in their mind
she kept it quiet for a long time
and she was concerned at first i knew i
was leaving for about three months
colorado i knew for about a month
and today i was just when i hung up with
her
i was thinking about how i felt you know
like jesus what did i feel like two
nights before that
i was holding on by dear emily
they were coming at me from all
directions
i had about six [ __ ] people looking
for
and they were coming at me from all
direction
and i was chucking and driving at the
same time that i was chuckling and
driving
i'm robbing with three hands
and i'm just trying to put money away to
go on this mission to colorado
and we're already set to go and i can't
boogie
but
i wasn't worried about that way
i was really worried about
what i was doing like can you imagine
being 19 i know those people have done
this before
but i really thought about what the [ __ ]
i had done at that age
it's weird i don't
whenever i listen to these stories
i don't picture you as a 19 year old kid
because when you were saying earlier
that by my age you were married and i
was like jesus christ he he went to
colorado that early
you're i just you're such a good
storyteller just imagine it as you
now
to think of it as a 19 year old kid
doing that stuff is
19. compared to me at 19 in college
i was sitting there going what the [ __ ]
am i gonna do with my goddamn life
you know
my buddy had just lost money in the
super bowl
i was working for [ __ ] peanuts
you know who the [ __ ] was i kidding i
was at that bar three nights a week
acting like tony [ __ ]
bananas snort and a half gram of coke
that's 40 a pop
that's 120 when you're 19
a week that's 480. that's not even
including the [ __ ] alcohol
that's on including the meals out with
your [ __ ] [ __ ] friends which i
enjoyed
every single one of those times but i
was saying
that's where my head was at at 19. was i
going to get a job
listen i was one of those dudes that
wanted to job but i didn't want a job i
wanted a job that i didn't have to show
up to
and i was going to hold out though
somebody gave it to me in my perverted
[ __ ] disgusting mind
that sounded like the perfect job and
eventually i had to go to work and i did
go to work for a while i really did work
for a while
but i needed cash to go to colorado
like i needed a cushion because i could
shovel snow
or get a job as a garbage man in those
days because all my friends had ends at
those places
but it was the end of april how much
snow was there going to be
probably not much that much so i was
trying to get a job
once i thought about the [ __ ] no snow
i was like i'm gonna need some money for
a few [ __ ] weeks
so i wanted to rob as much as i could
and i wasn't robbing i was trying to get
that one drug deal that's all i [ __ ]
wanted
and he left
and i was bummed and then he broke down
and he came back
nope
no part of you thought of getting just a
regular job or
i thought about it a thousand times
but deep down inside i was too far
behind on the money i owed
i was too far behind on where i stood
with
people who cared for me and people who
loved me
i was just too far [ __ ] behind man
and guess what i wasn't going nowhere i
wasn't i was trying to go into
vocational school
first i was gonna be a plumber then i
switched it to masonry
then i quit after five weeks because
the guy fired me from the masonry job
so for you to be in the masonry program
you had to be have a job in the
mainstream job
then i got a job
in a brick place
so i got put back into the masonry job
then i got fired from the brick players
because
they wanted me to hold bricks and 20
below [ __ ] weather with you know a
hooded sweatshirt
no heater in the warehouse
so i was just i was looking for a job
but not really
i wanted a job that i could go there and
have pork chops
something to give me a line of blow
that's what i [ __ ] that's
jesus christ that's how [ __ ] i was
at 19. if you really want to know so
that's what i thought i thought i was
going to get a job bartending
or i could be the life of the party and
pour drinks and make two three hundred a
night
and do that three four nights a day
and snort coke and wear like a vest
and try to be [ __ ] cool with the
ladies but that that never panned out
for your uncle joey
that plane really does
nah every job i got that made me work
like an off day it's like i had a good
job
as a bartender but it it wasn't the
bartending i
necessarily wanted to do
i wanted to do small pub
type bartender
where you know everybody and [ __ ] like
that but it didn't really matterly
you know i think about when i talk to
people who have given up
things in their hometown to come out
here
or just to leave and i've remembered how
how hard it was how hard it was for me
because like the hardest thing i was
gonna like
i knew i was gonna miss my friends
and i knew i was gonna miss this
environment it had been all i ever known
new jersey and new york city that whole
area is all i ever knew you know
and that's all i ever knew but i i was
ready to get out i was so excited to
leave
part of me wanted to get out and part of
me [ __ ] didn't
but i remember the fear i went through
in that car driving from yeah new jersey
to colorado the [ __ ] fear
of wanting to get there
because i wanted to see what this was
all about
it was [ __ ] brutal
like that's how you know and i even
wrote about it today when i went over to
the court that's what i wrote about
today
that's what was that had me all [ __ ]
up today was the fear of the unknown
just the chance i took
but once i took that one chance it was
all over after that because i can knew i
knew
i could do it now i lived on my own for
[ __ ] 10 months in colorado i paid
rent every month
i bought my own groceries i used to buy
a head of lettuce and oscar maya salami
and chop it up with an italian dress and
what
that shit's good to go papa
you still were oh we were talking about
sloppy joes in the green room
i haven't had a sloppy joe in probably
10 years
that's because you're [ __ ]
but tell them what you did have telling
me uncle joey hooked you up in santa
barbara oh my goodness
okay
so we went to tomah
it's a italian place right on the beach
right near the uh pier and and no not
the period like the uh wherever the
boats go the marina
and uh it was great we called up because
we we thought you had to get a
reservation
and the guy
saved two spots at the bar for us he had
two he had two places already set for my
dad and i got there
i i didn't even look at the menu i just
got the lasagna
and my dad got the capillini i think it
was i have a picture of it it's the
biggest shrimp i think i've ever seen
and the little lasagna i ate every
single bite of it
and uh went back to your room and you
fell asleep
like the savage that you are but you
probably ate some chips when you went
home you had a good time with the chips
this weekend yeah candy or something you
know what you're [ __ ] when you're
eating
2 000 milligrams so yeah if you're
[ __ ]
thinking about leaving where you live
man
it's [ __ ] hard
just do it that way sometimes you gotta
do it but you know what you can always
come back
and look like the other 10 dudes who
failed who gives him
but at least you [ __ ] went at least
you went for it
that's what they do they put you up
against the wall like this guy left too
and he thought he this guy had the
answer too
but he came back and look at this guy he
had all the answers he was making
millions sure he was
why the [ __ ] is he back here on the bar
right working off the tab
you know
that's what i dreaded
and when i went back in 84 i didn't go
back like that
i went back because i missed that
[ __ ] lifestyle
i didn't go back because i failed i
always knew
i was going back to colorado
i just wanted to know when i wanted to
see what i could get out of my step-dad
but at the end it was all a waste of
time right i should have stayed in
colorado i could have probably been a
different person today you think so
you never know
what was going on god damn lying to you
because
one of the reasons why i went back to
north bergen
was because
they had put something together i had
done in aspen
a burglary and i knew what any day they
were going to nail me and if they nailed
me for that burglary
they were gonna nail me for
10 other [ __ ] burglaries
maybe i don't know give or take
because they were drug dealers so i
don't know if they reported it
but i was such a kleptone those days
god knows what i took
god knows what i [ __ ] took
[ __ ]
it's crazy it's all great and then it's
crazy how your life changed
well
listen i could take these things and
sweep them under a [ __ ] carpet
oh i can tell you them and you can feel
better
and ain't all [ __ ] roses
and ain't no [ __ ] uh
you gotta work for everything i did
triple runs i
i moved to seattle i
i sweated out two years up there
you know this was real this was [ __ ]
real
i
i don't mind putting in the work
it's just i in my head by the time i'm
54
i i i i want to have some time where
it's a little bit more relaxed
a little bit about that when you get the
first right yeah i'm not that worried
about it right now worry about when
you're 28
that's the other thing whatever you
think ahead of time
all that thinking i did
was a waste of time because i never
thought about the podcast
i never even saw it coming here we are
five years later
so don't think about nothing
because you never know what life's got
down the corner
as long as you stay positive
and you're willing to try new [ __ ]
things
you never know me
you never [ __ ] you know you
understand me
now i'm talking about working hard you
need to [ __ ] rest
night after night two people lay in the
same bed like two mooks
but when it comes time to buy a new
mattress
only one gets their way
until now introducing helix sleep where
you can buy matches online customized
for both of you for hundreds of dollars
instead of thousands go to helix
sleep.com answer a few simple questions
based on four key preferences and the
result will be a custom sleep profile
used to build you the most comfortable
mattress you'll ever ever sleep on your
mattress will arrive at your door in
about a week and shipping is a hundred
percent free
as an and for couples helix customizes
each side of the mattress can you
believe that
personalize
to suit each of your bodies
the way you boat sleep
helix customers report a 30 improvement
in overall sleep quality overall that
includes nappy nunu you have a hundred
nights to try it out and if you don't
love it they'll pick it up for you free
and give you a hundred percent refund no
questions asked a hundred nights that's
three months
if you don't love it 100 refund no
questions asked that's why everyone from
gq magazine
the forbes are all talking about helix
sleep do me a favor just to help you out
just to make you more relaxed
just to make you because if you sleep
better you'll be more proficient out
there in the field go to helix
go to helixsleep.com
joey
helixsleep.com joey and get 50 off your
order that's helixsleep.com
joey
again helixsleep.com
slash joey and get fifty dollars off
your order lee what are you giggling
about lee
i'm just giggling i'm enjoying it okay
you're enjoying it all right that's what
i need for you that will enjoy me over
here
while i'm trying to read and struggle
here i'm looking at lee and lee's
looking sharp today
he's got a blue sweater on his beard is
tight
he's got a few spots on his head but
when doesn't he have some [ __ ]
ailment it's either the spot in his head
or the [ __ ] up eyebrow
or the [ __ ] ingrown toenail on the
eyeball it's always something with this
poor guy
anyway
but what lee is sporting with all new
fan this
is a beautiful
mvmt watch pronounced movement
it's a beautiful watch
i had one too
mine slipped i'm waiting for a coat to
get a new one but between you and i if
they don't send me a coat i'm gonna buy
one anyway because it was that much of a
night it was that nice of a watch i
usually wore it under my sweater when
i'm on stage
it's stylish it fits
it looks really good and you know what
the most important thing it doesn't cost
normal leg
that's the most important thing this
company was started by two broke college
kids
that wanted to wear stylish watches
but couldn't afford them so they started
their own watch company
they started this with social media
videos they launched into podcasts
youtube radio you name it these savages
did it
movement watches they start at 95
dollars at a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 for the same watch
movement figured out that by selling
online they were able to cut out the
middleman
and the retail market providing the best
possible price for you
listen to this they got classic design
quality construction
and style
minimalism they've sold over a million
watches
worldwide and 160 countries listen to
what we're going to do for you you know
i love you to death i want you to look
good for the fourth of july you don't
have a jacket on you want to look sharp
you don't want to look like a moog
people ask you what time it is you could
talk to them you know how it is you want
to mingle you have to have a nice watch
what i'm going to do for you is get 15
off today with free shipping
and free returns something ma'am you
don't like the black watch you want it
in gray
there you go but do me a favor go to mt
mvmtwatches.com
church again
going
to mvmt
church you're going to love this watch
and you're going to save
four
to five hundred dollars look at lee's
watch
this watch has a really clean design
and i'll tell you what every time i see
lee out people always say how nice the
watch is again go to mvmtwatches.com
church
join the movement you savages
i want to thank helix i want to thank
mbmt i want to thank my brother lisa and
i want to thank ahn and i want to thank
you savages
for always being there for us
tonight we decided just to go old school
chit chat see what's on each other's
mind
be very uh jenna sequoia
if i like to say
don't forget thursday night the tumblr
brewing
and then sadly i think the last the uh
the [ __ ] ice house already sold out
so
that's how fast we're doing that beside
that i'll see you savages wednesday
night get ready to rock
that's all i'm telling you get ready to
rock wednesday night eight o'clock
have a great night thank you for
listening to the church and what's
happening now
thank you for the love you know we love
you too
hey
so
so
[Music]
so
you